Let's apply this idea of the degrees of freedom to samples and populations.
Let's say these are values in a population. We can pick any n values from this
population to have the sample of size n. If n is five, let's say we pick these
five. There are five degrees of freedom. If we pick a sample of size n, we have
n degrees of freedom. But then we have to calculate the sample standard
deviation. And to do this, we need the sample mean. To find the mean, we add up
each value in our sample, divide by the number in our sample, and then we get x
bar. That means that the sum of all the values in the sample has to be x bar
times n, this is just like that example you did before where you have n values
that must add to 10. In that case, you had n minus 1 degrees of freedom and the
same applies here. In our population, when we need to pick a sample of size n,
we now have a restriction that nth value has to ensure that they add to x bar
times n. In other words, n minus 1 of the values may vary as long as the nth
value results in that same sum to get the same average. N minus one is called
the effective sample size. Since the sample standard deviation depends on x
bar, there are n minus 1 degrees of freedom. You might ask, well why do we
divide by n with the population standard deviation if that also uses x bar?
Well, with the population we can't replace certain values with other values,
like we can with samples, because we already have all possible values of the
population. Degrees of freedom are the number of pieces of information that can
be freely varied without violating any given restrictions. Think of degrees of
freedom as the number of independent pieces of information available to
estimate another piece of information. Only n minus 1 values are independent
after we know the mean. As the degrees of freedom increases, the t-distribution
better approximates the normal distribution.